riah about sequential semester a
stochastic optimization for for some big
data problem so let me see oh this one
doesn't work oh yeah okay so outline so
I will first talk a little bit about the
background about the optimization and
why we want to do the stochastic
optimization that I will talk about some
recent progress we made in this
sequential circuits optimization so I
talked two methods
so we studied and explained why it's
better than the batch optimization
methods then I would talk a little bit
about strategies for distributed
computing why is with shy about mini
batch SDC a the the stochastic
optimization method we worked on the
other one is a little bit different
scheme so there there could be
potentially a few different schemes for
discrete computing so I will describe
something happens to related to to the
two methods why is a CCA the others vrg
so okay the background the background is
in machine learning so we are
interesting kind of optimization problem
but it has a special structure the
special structure mainly we are
interesting looking at is sum over data
so essentially so we want to do an
optimization and that the optimization
problem has some over data each fi will
be a simpler structure and then we are
interested in the sum over some simple
functions example is the like logistic
equation richer your question this query
question or have this form so this is
generally for supervised learning if we
have a large data then we also think
about twin distributed computing for
that but the for now let's just look at
this particular problem and
try to see what how do we take advantage
of the special structure so if we want
to look at this optimization we can have
simple to complex forms the simplest
form is a single machine single core
which is what we will look at first in
particular in our setting what we want
to say is in this scenario we can use
some kind of sequential algorithm like
SVD and so on or were our stochastic
modifications of SGD the this can be
implemented efficiently on a single core
single machine if we move to the
multi-core then we have some other
scenarios but the general americorps is
a shared memory machine so you have a
relatively cheap communication so you
can do something which you cannot do for
example if you have multiple machines so
multiple machines you have a more
expensive or communication especially
you want to synchronize the
communication and this way actually we
will talk about later on so why is we
were starting from simple but the dam we
will look at is synchronized the
communication that you can have if your
communication is really a barrier you
really have to think about asynchronous
updates which hopefully can reduce your
communication but we will not talk about
this scenario in this talk this will be
really to make scale large generally
what I will talk about is from simple to
complex so first the simple one means we
can do sequential algorithm one more
complex we will think about how to
reduce communication first we will look
at this problem just the what I wrote
down earlier this is the optimization
problem with a special structure and if
we know anything about the optimization
where you take a calculus class you know
the standard method or the first one you
would heard about is gradient descent
which basically has these kind of update
rules one thing I want to compare with
is compared with the other approach is
to say how fast this method can converge
to the optimal solution
generally you have these kind of results
you come for local minimum what is
commbuys were not doesn't matter but the
convergence rates depend on conditions
so in the photo for the case of
illustration we are more interested in
strongly convex and smooth functions for
this kind of problem we know the
convergence rate is linear so those are
classical results basically the the
convergence rate after K iterations it
will be something smaller than 1 to the
K so that's a generally referred to as a
linear convergence in the optimization
literature this is can be consider
reasonably fast as long as your
condition number is not too large this
is in worse condition number is not too
small or as long as 0 we use a constant
then your convergence fast compared to
this so there's a disadvantage about
doing the gradient so what a 50-round
age is if I starting with a special form
like this if I calculate the gradient it
takes any summations so you each time
you have gradient descent you would
calculate the gradient which would
require n summations which is very
costly if your n is large for the big
data problem now one fix to that is to
say we don't have to compute the exact
gradient especially in the beginning we
probably want to compute some simpler
say approximation to the gradient and
very natural approximation of the greedy
and it just using sub samples so here is
just a stochastic optimization what we
refer is mainly to say that the gradient
is subsampled where to the computation
way to a random subsample of of this guy
and then instead of using the true
gradient we use approximation and
typically when we choose the classic
Whedon's and which is the size of p with
1 but we can use a mini batch we can
have a size of p is larger than 1 but
this is general idea the idea is we want
to use the approximation of the gradient
if we look at this approximation so
there are two things why is this is
unbiased
Estimator if you you're starting to to
look at just to add approximation the
other thing is that there has to be era
because because it's not the exact
solution but it's a it's approximation
the arrow because it's on bias it's
variance so when we talk about how how
accurately this guy close to that we
already talked about the variance how
large the bearings and when you reduce
sample size from n to P some of sides
then essentially what you do is you are
using a more efficient computation but
the introduced the variance and the how
large that variance turns out to be
important as far as the convergence it
goes so this will play a central role
when we talk about the method now let's
compare with sgt and GD actually of
course has a faster converge a
computation per step because you don't
use a full sample use a smaller sample
you get a slower rate this one word here
it is because of variance so you you you
you introduce a variance of the gradient
and the approximation that works basics
1 over t so you cannot get rid of that
for for graduate for gradient descent we
know that it's a it's worse computation
for start but it has nowhere else
therefore you have h geometric original
convergence for the same kind of problem
strongly convex and smooth overall so
this says SVD is fast in the beginning
because the slower convergence of it
because of the faster computation and
you do not need a very accurate or
greedy --nt at the beginning in the end
eventually once goes on and on you will
need a more accurate of gradient because
you want her accuracy therefore the
variance turns out to kill the h TT so
you send sure as we the fast in the
beginning for the worst low are
sympathetically it's linear this is
known in other day this is shalini so
you you draw this line if you just
compare the standard sgt versus gradient
descent
what your card is this curve basically
reading this and it's a cost lower in
the beginning because of the
computational cost but that eventually
is getting faster because you have a
linear rate faster convergence rate here
SVD you have faster beginning because
you don't need to accurate a gradient in
the beginning and you have a faster
computer population per step but in the
end why you really need a far more
accurate ingredient it doesn't provide
that you have various then I'd say it's
become slower so a typical strategy
people actually do that in practice I
know several people who start doing that
because of that so we can use the SGD
first to - to the training and at some
point let's say at this point if you
look at the marginal rate of convergence
gradient already become faster then what
happens you switch to the switch to the
gradient descent or some other fancier
method like out BFGS but essentially
therefore in the same category they
compute a full gradient they don't use X
for summation and they're essentially
what we call patch methods notice it has
three methods
so generally that's the scheme this
thinking I mean makes a lot of sense
until recently until I think one more
two years ago people realize that in
fact this is not necessary I'm just from
a single core single machine
optimization probe went of view this is
not the best approach we can do better
and the batter is through sarcastically
wisdom but better of course because we
have a variance in the stochastic
algorithm we want to fix the variance
problem so that's what I'm going to talk
about so I will talk about if we
summarize actually converge fast
computations till oh that's a gradient
descent Gd that's GD h GD convergence of
convergence to low but competitions fast
and the key I want to again say is that
that because you are not asking your
your gradient accurately you have a
variance and what you should do is you
you wanna fix STD problem you you think
about fixed variants problem so that's
what actually made a very recent a few
papers about that
so about improving Sgt the central idea
some some of the papers like the French
before this French paper has very very
long proofs you don't understand what's
going on so I don't understand nobody
understand except to authors but the the
point is essentially if you do
stochastic optimization if you have a
faster convergence it has to be reduced
variance period there's no other way
around as far as I understand and that
this makes it more clear so I will talk
about this first just should just show
you what why why this is can work with
the variance reduction and here is
another work with shy about using a kind
of traditional with them in some sense
this algorithm has been known for a
while for at least ten years but the the
importance here at least our work is
analysis but also stochastic it actually
turns out to be important to be
stochastic not the deterministic so is
when we do this kind of SGD where
whatever improvement as Seca or whatever
they they need to be statistics
they need to be randomized and nowadays
a lot of people also in the optimization
community interests in randomized
randomized caught in the descent
randomized whatever basically so here is
it's a view about gradient descent from
the variance reduction so this one
hopefully explains if there's a one
slice you'll take home maybe maybe
that's that's what it is so if I have a
objective function have a this special
structure so what I do is I I started
with some W tilde which close to the
optimal solution for example after you
you to one round of STD you can carry
something close nothing exactly equals
your optimal but close enough there are
you do a compensation the conversation
is so looking at the following so you
take this gradient you you subtract your
your own gradient at any particular
point
and plus you are your your your fou
Carinthia this one sum up to be 0
because this fluke radiant is simply
some of your your average of your your
individual gradient so essentially this
term sum sum up to be 0 therefore your
this function is equivalent to this Sun
basically you do now know you want to
rewrite that they you know a different
form so why you want to rewrite in that
different for what what happens that I
can do stochastic with the end with this
function instead of this function it is
apply the same except if I do the
passive cui Jian with this function the
variance is reduced so that's a key
point here if I I look at this is
equivalent by using this compensation
but then I my SPR giru is actually
looking at greatest classic region with
this representation so this
representation just do this SVD and if
you expand out in the original function
it becomes take the gradient - this guy
which is the PC lease term Plus this
term so so essentially you just have to
a compensation and the point is the
original sgt has a large variance it's a
fixed variance constant variance there's
no way you avoid but this guy has small
- why is that it's actually not
difficult to see here is why this has
small variance variance actually goes to
0 essentially because once you have the
your two days close to W star after
while you go awhile you'll find a W
tilde expand at that point this is the
close to 2 to your periodic so this guy
close to 0 this guy close to that simply
because this will be close to W star
this guy should be close to W star
therefore this should be simple closed
and the this one should it be subtract
each other it should it be close to 0
this guy should be close to 0 as well
therefore they're adding together close
to 0 so the bottom line is once you two
eventually what you can show is that the
convergence of this algorithm become
linear the linear convergence has a
particular form and the and each
iteration of this algorithm look at the
only y example therefore computation is
fast its computational fast and has a
linear convergence so that's the key
point
and in fact if you compare this this
convergence to the gradient descent you
use your faster convergence the faster
convergence is following roughly
speaking just in a very loose way so we
have a condition number at times this is
generally greedy and descent but the
each gradient descent will require
looking at any examples so total
communication a total computation cost
to have this condition number times n
will be B what you can and if you look
at the other example what you have is in
the instead of n times condition number
of this one you have n plus so so it's
really it's n times goes to n plus which
gets you a lot of benefits because one
it's a large which is typically what the
tip big data problem is you you really
have a large N and you don't want to
have this one you really want to have
these this one is essentially say if n
is large enough you just go to a few
round of n then it's a sufficient it's
always well condition basically that's
and under the condition number is
defined as as is basically the gain of
this kind of stochastic algorithm when
you crack the variance problem is a
substantial what is a large so that's a
point there's another algorithm we okay
here actually is it's just the example
of this is a variance variance of SGD is
actually flat it doesn't get reduced
because you don't have any compensation
if you do this Serg eventually you get
reduced
you keep updating your W tilde the W
tilde and your updates goes to reduce so
that the point is it can get reduced you
do converse not call my smoking on
comments problems and then they have a
you see the variance gets gets smaller
and you feel to the convergence it's a
smoother because of that so there's just
some illustration so there's another
method which actually turns out also
very interesting method it's it's a
little bit more classical method about
do you want to do coordinate so you'll
start with a problem a primal problem
you look at a dual problem and you look
at a dual objective function which I
don't write here but essentially your
problem is your primal rate it's a sum
of two and a deal basically the
derivative of your your functions
essentially what it says that you want
to optimize you you look at the
optimization in term of say alpha and we
update alpha you eventually the schedule
and algorithm which people use for
example solving SVM and a song so so
this is our I know and a recently like
Shah and I analyzed this one particular
getting similar results to say this one
actually turns out has a fast
convergence behavior as well and that
the reason of that again you can look at
this as stochastic are wisdom and it's a
reason of that will be reduce from
errors so if we look at the original SGD
so let's starting with original stt this
will be what people do we say treaty
basically each each you have you have
your loss function you have a regular
riser so each time you take derivative
and that's what she gives you that's the
RTD function now you you can you can
look at the how it's update in the tool
but essentially the alternative about VT
is the this SDC a it's very similar form
you have the derivative a loss function
but instead of a derivative of w you
replace that by n times alpha i the
reason you can do that is essentially i
replace this guy because w is a sum of
alpha chain it's a average of
and times alpha alpha I essentially I
will take the expectation just take away
of data components that I will get
basically a stochastic approximation of
W so our double stochastic in some sense
why is the KC not only on this term but
the case they are in terms of W using
that your representation so this one
comes from this guy I've just pick I
because I strand up
so essentially I look at this so if you
take expectation is the same is
eventually it's a the same formula but
but you can at your update essentially
this one this in the primal form you can
write that in the duo form
it's a to perform is only one one of the
parameter gets updated the other keep on
change so this is essentially the dual
core interessant you look at the each
one look at one particular to you you
update that and and and you're doing
that so that that's basically the idea
about that
the main point okay is that if I study
that instead of in the do domain which
typical people study when they took a
look at the coded I sent what counted
decent methods they look at you but if I
look at the primordial mostly we are
interesting primal and the this is a
stochastic algorithm again if you think
about the SPT this one is one version of
SGD in terms in the sense of this is a
stochastic approximation of your
brilliant expectation of this one's
gradient so if you look at this way what
happens is that this one has some more
variance also simply because if you look
at this guy now you look at a deal
representation at the optimal it's the
same equation basically the point is
this guy goes to 0 simply because of the
identity of representation and that also
means the case of variance goes to 0
this one once use the castle variance
goes to 0 you know it's a you get fast
convergence so that's essentially the
similar result you will get and of
course when you prove those linear
results you need a stronger
then this goes to zero you want to say
this goes to right at the right rate for
SD CA you want to pounder the duality
gap too early the calf goes down in the
right rate for the SVR G you just reduce
optimality the various should be upper
bounded by the opponent optimality here
the variance should be bounded by to a
little cap so that's the thing this one
basically the mainly stays idea about
the reason idea once you have this new
stochastic optimization techniques even
get faster convergence than the standard
a batch learning wisdom that we will
think about a paralyzation simply
because what we are doing the sequential
what we are doing stochastic
optimization a sequential algorithm
sequential algorithms they are useful
while you implement that single core you
can do that sequentially if you do that
multiple core for example or if you do
that in multiple machines they cannot be
parallelized and the one approach there
are different approach to that but I
will talk about two things which can
lead to paralyzation one approach is
mini batch so in mini batch instead of
using one example you using maybe say a
thousand examples simultaneously as a
mini batch dependent problem it can be
hundreds of thousands and I know you you
your disrepute across that I see a
hundred machine each one handles for
example 100 or 1000 examples then that
night can be paralyzed you you you will
save communication the computation about
the mini batch is can be more extensive
more costly than the communication cost
in that case what you can do is just
into a mini batch SDC mini SD C is very
similar to SDC basically our similar
proof will carry over so that's
essentially without change except the
problem is if you do the mini batch
simple implementation
it was stall down your convergence it
will not accelerate linear
as your processor cause you want to
asset for example if you are a hundred
processors you really want to say
computation of hundred times faster but
it will not happen while to the linear
it will be reduced again the solution
what we do is of course a lot of people
familiar with acceleration nest of
acceleration methods the the other
alternative I would say if you don't use
acceleration you can't use second order
information try to play or run with that
this is a more tricky but I think it's
doable it's just as hard to prove
anything
this one is much easier to prove things
so so we will look at this so that we
can prove something here is one version
I don't want to explain that too much
but essentially this one is one version
of accelerated mini batch as TCA which
worked with sha about and this is a nibs
paper this one is better than vanilla
SDC because of vanilla SDC it can slow
down once you go from stochastic mini
batch size goes up especially what means
price.if mini batch size goes to end up
to n that you know it's become bachelor
so it will have slow convergence the
question is how large it goes you can
still have a good convergence here is
what happens you have this is virtual
with them accelerate the accelerator
brilliant this is a mini batch stuff and
the wise mini batch codes are large
Elijah this one essentially means me
batches n size right it will have slow
convergence wise ministers mini batch
size gets larger and larger convergence
to the slower becomes lower eventually
the heat this kind becomes like like
like bachelor but the question is how
large it can be you can tolerate the
still has fast convergence turns hours
when you do the acceleration you can
tolerate a fairly large mini batch size
for example in this particular example
you have you have a small mini batch as
TC a versus a larger one you still have
the reasonable size he almost has no
loss of your convergence speed basically
means if you use some more processors
you get a linear speed-up so that's
that's conclusion well here you really
pace a pace if you do the batch of
wisdom you pace in terms of convergence
speed so another update I want to say so
the this is one way to achieve another
way to achieve that is the following
scenario let's say you have n processors
each one have a 1 over m and you you
want to solve that independently for
each processors and try to combine it in
that case each processor you can do a
sequential algorithm because you do not
have to parallel lies that so you do a
sequential algorithm for each processor
and combine that one simple combination
strategy is following so I will split
this data into am different machines
each one have 1 over m number of
examples that I will parallel eyes
separated at the computer WI up to WM
eventually I will take an average this
is one run scheme people studied it has
some understanding of some assumptions
you can have some Cerreta core result to
say this is good but in practice usually
this is not as comparative to the you
solving the whole problem now let's say
if we want to take on from this this
idea to say we can solve problem
sequentially on each machine very fast
we know we have things like Seca which
which achieved that problem that we want
to see if we want to synchronize over
different machines is there any way we
can we can do better than than than this
well at least try to more a few more
steps getting strong getting good
performance so here is one possible
improvement you simple strategy run
independent delay you can run sequential
algorithms and a computation efficient
and that is a disadvantage is
practically it's inferior solution you
you want to synchronize more you just
repeat this step the question is how do
you want to repeat right so you once you
cut this one and what you go from there
here is where actually you you want to
look at again look at in this form i'm
processors you want to say how do i want
to speed this up and this is scream it's
basically the same as a s vrg the
proposal is basically the same as vrg
exactly to a parallel version so in the
original strg we showed is a sequential
you'll look at this particular
transformation of your function you to
ask you crunch oh we know this when you
do this transformation various gets
reduced which means all the function
become very similar and then what
happens is once you do that in the
original or original version so you do
them sequentially here we do that in
parallel but in parallel what we do is
we try to minimize this function with a
modified doubling each time so each time
we just modified ugly and we solve that
independently basically this one is
iterative algorithm the main point of
this one again you have a fast
convergence so I don't want to go over
that but essentially the idea is if you
do this algorithm you have a fast
convergence very fast for example
original scheme you have a wide staff
here I probably have only two steps I
only need to three steps it's not like
hundred steps but two steps so that's
that the main point about this approach
and this one again is it's using very
similar why is if you look at the we
talked about two algorithm points as vrg
where SDC a sec were top a mini batch as
we are G we can have a parallel version
so they are all connected to each other
the ideas
so in summary so what we have is we have
optimal addition in machine learning
people ask me like an inn ask what's a
what's machine learning brings to the to
the optimization so I have to say one
thing is a new problem but in this
particular structure so we have this
particular structure sum over the data
which hasn't been series to look at by
the optimization community they look at
that but they don't take advantage of
this structure so here what we do is we
take a bunch of a structure traditional
method they really don't they have
nothing to say about that special
structure well the more than stochastic
algorithm to say you have this structure
you can take advantage of that and of
course what's resulting algorithm is
faster rate but it's sequential
algorithm the real next step is to say
let's say we want to optimize this a
paralyzation what we should do so I give
some ideas but there are really
different issues and I think this is a
lot of work can be done to say you have
a sequential always and we know it's
good how we can try to parallel I say
okay thank you
basically for convex problem we after
every two iterations to a box we update
W with the next every to a box will be
to a W for non-convex fine let's give
you a concrete answer
non-convex problem 5 v f ox update W
tilde commas problem every to a box